sur le terrain donc la guerre continue
comme en témoigne ce reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux jacquat bouchard
patrice du tertre et jean-claude gautron
les seuls journalistes à s'être rendu
dans la région de dezful là où le
président de la république monsieur
banny saab avait choisi d'installer son
pc et là où les irakiens avaient choisi
eux de semer la terreur parmi la
population civile
un an
quand téhéran sous le portrait géant de
l'imam khomeiny vendredi ont pris pour
la victoire sur l'irak dans l'assistance
quelques blessés témoignent par leur
présence des épreuves subies
car les cent mille fidèles présents
savent que le sort des armes semble
pencher en faveur de l'adversaire
le port de khoramshahr est coupée du
reste du pays
la raffinerie d'abadan est momentanément
perdu à phase capitale de la province
pétrolière du khouzistan est menacée
téhéran n'a connu que de rares alertes
mais dans d'autres villes les proches du
front l'artillerie et l'aviation de
bagdad n'ont pas épargné les populations
à des sons ce fut même un carnage
les irakiens ont lancé cinq fusées seuls
cinq contre cinq quartiers différents de
la ville en pleine nuit
les engins ont creusé des normes cratère
dont on a retiré près de 200 cadavres
non
des foules possède bien une base
aérienne mais éloignée des quartiers qui
ont été touchés la ville est devenue le
symbole de la résistance et de la
mobilisation populaire le président bani
sadr il y avait d'ailleurs installé son
poste de commandement pendant dix jours
allez
dans leur colère les habitants prennent
à partie l'amérique bien sûr mais aussi
l'union soviétique
principal pourvoyeur de l'irak en
matériel militaire et en munitions
controversées le plus meurtrier n'était
pourtant pas le premier
la retire irakiennes avaient déjà frappé
au parent atteint l'objectif est utile
d'obliger la population à évacuer la
ville il n'a pas été atteint bien que
des foules soit prise en tenaille par
les colonnes irakiennes qui sont à une
vingtaine de kilomètres
faire à l'hôpital où les blessés sont à
une jeune doctoresse confirme la
détermination des habitants
demain
nous resterons quoi qu'il advienne
déclare-t-elle en substance nous
résisterons à cette guerre l'ayatollah
calque ali l'ancien procureur tant
redoutée des tribunaux et à la
médiocrité à des foules
quelques heures après l'oréal comme reçu
les chefs religieux il a endossé
l'uniforme et pour venir galvaniser les
énergies le grand le seul véritable
vainqueur de cette bière raticide c'est
israël notre ennemi commun déclare
l'ayatollah
la guerre sera longue
concluait calcalist longue et
terriblement meurtrière pour l'iran
comme en témoignent ces images de
soldats
débarquant en pleine nuit d'un avion
militaire les cercueils de leurs
camarades tués offrant au milieu des
cris et des chants funèbres
ces hommes invoque le nom de comme eni
qui a menacé de proclamer bientôt la
guerre sainte
je dois l'avouer nous nous en étions pas
aperçu le président de la